- DESHAUN, STOP LIKING JERSEY SWAPS AND LET ME IN.
Front office told me to give you this.
- How do I FORCE them to trade me?
- JAMES HARDEN ISSUES HEARTFELT TWEET TO HOUSTON.
- I have to speak to The Beard.
- THIS STOP IS…DIAMOND HEIGHTS.
- Before you enter, we have a few unwritten rules—
- That is why we don’t leave Gridiron Heights—
- NOW ENTERING...HARDWOOD HILLS.
- Whoaaaa. Athletes get to just go wherever they want.
- Too…much…autonomy…
- Oh, great. More new people.
- KYRIE, I SWEAR. I DON’T KNOW THESE GUYS.
- IF WE’RE A SUPERTEAM, WHY DON’T I FEEL SUPER?
- So you want to cause a scene in Houston?
Now publicly insult your teammates.
- What?
Uhh...
- Do it.
- Uh, J.J. Watt’s head is too small for his body.
[Gasps]
- Look, I'm sorry. I can't do this. J.J.'s head is perfect.
I guess I’m trapped.
Ahh!
- Unwritten rule #34, If anyone is having a really good day, no one can talk about it.
No ordering a Grand Slam from Denny’s if you’ve already eaten that day.
No enjoying your job out loud.
If someone’s car has hit every green light on main street,
they get to run stop signs to keep it going.
If your neighbor’s music is too loud, you get to peg them really hard—
Don’t write any of these rules down. That’s why this list is blank.